in Britain the words rail replacement
bus are not good words to hear it means
the Train you wanted to take isn't going
anywhere and instead everyone is going
to have to get a slow and lumbering bus
that will take at least twice as long
and be so much less comfortable if you
already left the purse station and the
rail company is required to get you to
your destination but there's no rule to
say how fast rail replacement buses are
the train travelers at the Pegman which
is why I was surprised to learn that for
just a few days things were happening
the opposite way around here between two
remote villages in the lowlands of
stopping there is a very red site
because to poison the normal schedule
here is to run every weekend usually
from Easter to the end of September the
bus replacement service was an idea that
was born out of some discussions between
some villages and the volunteers on the
railway and then once we realize that
there would be enough volunteers to run
this week we devised a timetable and
we've now got a daily service for this
week three 797b tiny Road between Red
Hills in Santa Monica and one Lochhead
in Dumfries and Galloway is shut returns
the diversion takes about 45 minutes by
Road but by luck there happens to be a
volunteer run narrow gauge railway
between the two there's all volunteers
there are not paying employees that lead
hills at all we're all just give up our
time for free tomorrow I'll be the guard
but today I'm the driver and we cover
all all the different roles it's been
used by people doctor surgery the people
commuting to work at the Museum of led
mining and a few other places besides
and yes it looks a little bit ridiculous
but you know what it works and it's not
often that you'll find a description to
your journey
makes your day better responses being
great so far this week and the villagers
are enjoying it and we've also had a few
extra tourists that wouldn't normally
get on a weekday coming to see us so
it's good publicity for the line and it
helps the villagers thank you to
everyone at the lead hills and one like
how the railway are if you are watching
this video on the day or so after it
goes up there may still be time to
travel on this service details in the
link are in the description along with
the dates when they're running steam
trains on the track this summer